hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the section on
the despisers of the body in part one of
the spoke zarathustra Friedrich
Nietzsche
is setting out in quite a clear and
succinct way what his views are on the
relationship between the body and the
spirit or the mind the guys and what he
calls the self and then the ego the ich
now all of these are interconnected with
each other as we're going to see and
Nietzsche himself is setting out
something a position that in effect
reverses the priority that most
traditions of moral thinking have given
to to the mind or the the you know what
does the thinking or the part of us that
says I by relation to the body which has
been devalued for many centuries and
indeed millennia and by many different
strategies you could say so
Nietzsche begins by talking about those
who do in fact despise the body
the fair act Aaron right those who dis
esteem is another way of translating it
or have contempt for it and then it's
this live as the living body they it's
not the Cooper which would be the corpse
or the body of the person who's engaged
in medical research it's the body that
we we experience that we live in and
there are indeed many people who have
despised it from you know Plato for
example all the way through people like
say Descartes talking about the body as
merely being a mechanism including the
brain that that's somehow the mind the
esprit right uses for its own purposes
and we can go on and on and on with all
their examples Nietzsche is attacking
them he's criticizing them saying really
you you don't understand
the proper relation so what is it that
these sorts of people do think is the
case well spirit is better than the body
or mind is better than the body the body
decays the body is temporal the you know
maybe the spirit or the soul or whatever
it is it's going to survive forever or
at least much longer than the body and
the other thing that they get mistaken
about is he says they're very proud of
this word I you know or we say ego in
German they're very proud of this and
they think that to be who they really
are what their identity is the self so
Nietzsche thinks they're wrong about
this and he says that they actually
still do in fact serve the self without
realizing it but they serve a self that
is damaged or diseased or in some way
corrupted or perverted and he'll he'll
say that here we go even in your folly
and contempt to you despisers of the
body you serve yourself I tell you your
self itself wants to die and turn away
from life yourself can no longer perform
the act which it most desires to perform
and what is that to create beyond itself
to generate something
or something outside of itself to
externalize itself to impose itself upon
other things to leave behind something
perhaps greater than itself something
that will not act as a legacy and just
replicate itself somehow but something
that will bring something new into the
world and Nietzsche says that this is a
sign of how the despisers of the body
are actually flaw damaged corrupted
degenerate now what is his actual
positive doctrine that he's laying out
here he says there is a priority of the
body and of the self
what is this priority he tells us that
the body is there's a beautiful little
phrase a great intelligence a
multiplicity with one sense a war and a
peace a herd and a herdsmen so the body
itself is incredibly complex and may not
in fact be a system entirely in harmony
with itself but there's a dynamic
tension and indeed conflict going on
within the body and the body is much
much faster than the mind or the spirit
he says your little intelligence which
you call spirit is an instrument of your
body a little instrument and a toy of
your great intelligence so what does
this imply our intelligence our thought
is not all going through our mind it's
not all going through our intellect or
our spirit as Nietzsche is calling it so
he goes on a little bit and he says your
your body has sense the sense feels the
spirit perceives it's never an end in
itself but sense and spirit they would
like to persuade you that they actually
are more than instruments that they're
the whole show that they're what the
body is therefore that there's a
teleology that leads us to them
whereas really it's the reverse why do
we have sense why do we have spirit to
serve the body the body is faster and
more important then he talks about the
self and he says sense and spirit our
instruments and toys be I it behind them
still lies the self the self seeks with
the eyes of the sense it listens to with
the ears of the spirit the self is
always listening and seeking it compares
it subdues it conquers it destroys now
that is what we would typically say well
that's what our mind does right our mind
is the thing during the comparison well
no the self is doing that and it lets
the mind think that the mind gets to do
that and the mind does its own little
you know proper activities and even gets
a little bit as we say too big for its
britches and wants to take over and run
everything but the self is always there
churning away behind that he says behind
your thoughts and feelings stands a
mighty commander he is called the self
and he goes on and he says yourself
laughs at your ego and it's proud
leapings
what is that I am the goal ego is not
the goal this is the self talking I pull
the strings as he says this the ego is
there for me not I for it and we'll go
through all the ways in which the self
does that but I do want to hit on one
other key points so far we've brought up
self and body and we've said well these
two are ontologically prior these are
the things that are really if we want to
call it the substance of the person and
the spirit the sense the ego those
things are as it were outgrowth of that
which then have a tendency to try to
take over but really can't because their
ground is in the self and the body now
one way of understanding this would be
to say alright so the
Adie itself then where what's its
relationship with the self
maybe the self is what's really
fundamental and the body is kind of an
outgrowth of that sort of an
epiphenomenon or a way in which the self
articulates itself and we here we might
think about Schopenhauer's will and its
relation to the body as well right
Nietzsche doesn't go that way instead he
endorses a thoroughgoing
materialism that centers upon the body
he says that here we go the the self
lives in your body ok so so far that
sounds kind of like saying that the self
uses the body but then he goes on
further and he says the self is your
body so what it is that you really are
is your body the finite body that you
have which is much much more than what
the mind has made of it much much more
than what any apparatus of the mind
likes a medicine or physiology or you
know all of the ways in which we carry
out our discussions about the body it's
more than any of those things and he
tells you that there is in fact a wisdom
within your body there's a more reason
in your body than in your best wisdom
right and who knows for what purpose
your body requires precisely your best
wisdom so the self the body they are the
same thing our mind are our construction
of our self that we call the ego
those are outgrowths of it that that the
self or body uses to be able to picture
itself to be able to do some of the
things that it does and that's it now he
goes on as well and talks about the ways
in which the self is creative and this
is very important for Nietzsche's moral
theory he tells us that the self is what
is creative it says to the ego feel pain
or let there be pain there and therefore
the ego suffers and gives thought to how
to end its suffering and it's meant to
think just for that purpose and HSS
that's part of what it does the self
says to the ego feel joy thereupon it
rejoices and gives thought to how it
might rejoice and it's meant to think
for that purpose and then he goes on and
he says hey you
this is steamers you critics of the body
you despisers of the body your despising
it this correct turn right therefore
actin is is this this attitude that you
take this affective stance that's
actually coming ultimately from the self
because the self is what creates esteem
or positive valuation actin right and
disesteem for octave octave and
Farrington there we go
and it also is what creates value there
and we'll deal it right so this is
really fundamental as well he goes on
further and he says that the body or the
self is what creates joy loosed and
sorrow they so all of these effective
things that tie together our entire
relation to the world and to ourselves
and that we have to think about nature
thinks because sometimes we get these
wrong these are all coming from the body
or the self so he says that this is what
the despisers of the body are getting
wrong this is what we if we want to
break out of their trap have to get
right and now one last word this implies
that we're never really going to have a
perfectly full comprehensible conception
of exactly what the self or the body is
but we experience it through living
through it and we can attain some
lucidity about its operations and
structure once we liberate ourselves of
contending or despising the body or the
self
you